do you guys picture like if your
testicle punctures you just jizz all
over the place that's what I was
thinking it's like B blood
[Music]
j a man says he does not want an apology
from his ex-girlfriend and still has
love for her even after she shot him in
the testicle no way oh my they have to
be Latino this couple his name is
Charlie Glenn oh well he's a creepy
looking white dude it's one of your
they're Appalachians explain yourself
Steve I I have nothing on this one dude
this is simp this is simpery that I've
never seen so she shot him in a ball
sack and he goes I still got another
testical did you say they're
Appalachians yeah they're Appalachian
types some people got that passion and
they like that kind of relationship
that's just turbulent yeah some people
like it it's passionate though it's
Mountain trash people have you guys ever
been in a relationship like that where
it was like you just toxic mous yeah bro
but not that bad no no one shot my
testicle no of course but like you know
get like at least the emotions of like
the highs and the lows I bet there's
something nice hell yeah dude I had two
girlfriends like that and they were both
not Japanese not Chinese not Vietnamese
not Filipino Malaysian I think I know
what you're I think I know what race
they are not Taiwanese not Taiwanese not
not Chinese not Mongolian not Filipino
no interesting Singaporean maybe no it
starts with the
K oh kazakstan
kakan and they
were
with a
K I think there's different kind of
cucko I know that is addicting though
when you have the tumultuous like ups
and downs if you've never had it before
it is really like hard to get out of
that yeah so this guy says uh he she
wanted me to take a walk with her and
then all of a sudden I found out oh she
has a pistol with her that's weird she
said it was a pet gun I said let me see
it cuz I'm not going anywhere with you
if you've got a gun and then she pulled
it out and shot me damn on the Dick what
did he do before yeah did he like it
what's what's what what made her want to
do that and why was he worried that she
had a gun I expected a little more
dialogue before the shot yeah yeah more
of a leadup see that's what I'm saying
there was probably a fight before and
she goes let's take a that's a
continuation she you know like how St it
in her head and you're not even there
anymore she had she's having an argument
with you and like in her head yeah while
you're sitting there yep yeah you
cheated on her like in the dream and she
woke up and she goes we're going to walk
outside and she's retaliating for you
cheating in the dream dude whenever dude
whenever I cheat on Nikki in the dream
it's the worst what do you say to to to
make it better there's nothing I can do
four hours the first four hours of the
day it's just like you're in big trouble
yeah I'm a piece of [__] when she wakes
up and she looks at you what does she do
is she
like she's she's she she doesn't start
with like that but like she's being cold
and I'm like and then like after a
couple hours she's like okay I got to
tell you something and I'm like okay
yeah what's up and then she's like yeah
I just had a dream last night and like
you're cheating on me you're really mean
to me about it and all the stuff and I'm
like oh that's why you she's like yeah
that's why who are you usually cheating
on her with in the dream is her dream or
Phil the Franco yeah guys oh that's why
she's upset she's upset that
you're Ray William Johnson she caught me
[__] the whole station crew all the
men no she it's usually just some random
person she's never seen before and then
she's like well then who is that she's
asking you but it's not you know cuz
women are really emotional obviously
that's true completely true stereotype
um all of them by the way all of them
every single one and she she just can't
help it so she just feels it has to like
almost sweat it out of her system by
just sitting there and you have to
apologize for what you haven't done not
even cuz she's not like illogical she
knows but she knows that she's doing
this she just yeah I go I'm sorry you
had a bad
dream say sorry for her and then you go
as you leave the room I'm sorry you
dreamed of me 69ing Jack's
films sh
Jack I know you had a vivid image of me
[__] deep throwing the [__] the
bartender friend that you got oh God the
which bartender oh Tipsy The Tipsy
Bartender true
true you saw me
going to Nikki's credit though if she
had a dream and she saw you just getting
deep throated that would be like
disturbing I don't want to think about
that hard toake up to you don't want to
think about me getting deep throated no
I am not a good friend dude yeah as soon
as you said it how do you get imagine
getting shot in the testicle though how
did it Miss the dick cuz if you aiming
at it how did it well maybe he he had it
moved upward where the belt is oh before
she did the shot dang and and he said he
didn't want an apology and then dude
maybe why is he so nice to her how do
you get shot the testicle without it
hitting your leg Yeah no clue maybe
maybe he was doing like a jump split
like yeah and go to try to dodge it he's
like
whoa miss all the vital organs is it is
it just me like a cowboy movie do you
guys picture like if your testicle
punctures just jizz all over the place
that's what I was thinking it's like B
blood
J it's like Ang
whites and then the paramedic shows up
and like step away from this man like oh
my God is he okay he like he just needs
to for a little
bit or or does he just feel it in his
stomach like you know you hit the balls
and you just feel your stomach is he
just holding his stomach the whole time
that's an interview i' would love to to
hear is like what's it like getting shot
in the Tes he's probably got really
really saggy balls so he said he says
that so there's a 911 call that's
transcripted and he says one shot um I
got shot I think he went through my
testicle and into my butt cheek and out
oh oh [__] you got a fat old ass huh
that Landing Strip it went right through
the landing strip and then he says I
still to this day love her and uh I only
want her to get better and if she ever
gets better well everything's on the
table basically that makes me very upset
why why cuz why do you why are you
treating them that way when they did all
this [__] up [__] cuz they're they're
hurt bro they're [__] hurt people
hurt people and you know what I say
empathy grow up emotionally dude if you
like that [__] and you like getting hurt
go get hurt some more then that's what
do you guys have any friends that have
come back from a really big infraction
in the relationship wait what do you
mean stay together even though something
really massively destructive happened oh
trying to I don't think so no I don't
know yeah usually they leave they do the
you know you have a death story for us
yeah are you setting this up worse oh
tell us what's worse than that it's like
hard to [__] all right the girl
[__] all the dudes I hope that these
people don't see this but like um I got
a friend who's like they they were
married for like over a decade um at one
point um one of them cheated with a
minor o how young and and did and
actually and actually did prison time
and uh and they still got back together
and they're still together this was the
guy or which the guy or the girl cheated
for sure it was the guy yeah cuz Bart's
about to say if it was the girl it's
okay I don't want I don't want to say it
cuz I feel like it's going to identify
I don't want to I don't want to say
either cuz I think I know you know I can
only think of certain people but but
they but they say together they were
married when it happened and they're
still married today can I ask if it's a
teacher don't say it don't say it no you
said it now I know now I know who it is
you're a Guess Who Pro I mean I think
it's fairly obvious yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah not not that I know who it is I
don't know who this is that's that's a
very I know the situation it's like how
do you get access to Young that's what I
was going to ask too that's what I asked
that's the biggest thing I've ever seen
like a like a like a friend a close
friend in a relationship and they
survived through that and they're
totally like they're they're great today
never crazy yeah they stayed together
because they had kids for the kids
or because of the [__] power of Jesus
Christ Our Lord dude right or they're
right or dies for each other yeah
they're they're Christian couples you
don't think that there's sometimes where
they get no fighting he's like well he
said [__] a kid
[__] I like good one cuz you could use
that forever it's a closure D I think
he's such a good he I mean they're s
they're such good I guess like good
natured people wait what one of them is
or she who knows yeah they're seventh
day Advantage talk yeah oh
[__] here's their
names I might as well just tell you but
yeah it's rough but I that that's one
thing that I was like o it's over it's
got to be over and then like it's never
been better I bet that shit's way more
common than we think I think that's the
de it is it is like abuse I agree I
think for it's forgiveness culture but
do you think do you think it's more
along the lines of like like you don't
know love the way I
do you guys don't know no no it's like
it's like it's like yes it's like what
if they believe that their love is so
strong it can go past these obstacles
can move mountains I think like when
you're good Nar when you're rooted in
let's say you have like high Faith uh I
think your your power of forgiveness
forgiveness dude but you know what do
you think it's true that once you see
the end result of all the [__] they went
through and they're still together do
you think that it's act the power of
love is stronger than everything the
power forgiveness that and the faith
[__] but also depends how old they are
too though bro like and how like if
they're a certain age How likely are you
going to be like all right I'm done with
this I'm going to start fresh I'm going
to start dating again like if you're
like 55 or something not even I think
even like late 30s or if you've been
with somebody for 10 [__] years right
I think your likelihood of being like
you know what I'm not going to I don't
want to redo this whole thing again
their their timeline when it happened
would be similar to if it happened to
you and to like right now so now we
could really narrow that oh [__] was it
me was it
me do you think doing that like
forgiving something that crazy and that
big doesn't come with like Rec
percussions like later because you're
enabling that now it's okay I think the
average person it will haunt them and it
will come back but I think if you're
like a [__] strong ass Christian bro
like it's they're they're operating a
different level think about the videos
that we've seen of like a it's like a
Serial Killer's trial and then the
family's member is like shaking or
whatever and then they're like you know
I forgive you I pray for you every day
and it's like dude this guy cut the
person's head off like your loved ones
got their head cut off and they're just
going it's comparable it's comparable to
a neoliberal when someone murders their
family and they're just like I want the
best for you like it's comparable to
that I'm praying that they release you
yeah I think there's definitely
something off about that like I think to
to the average person it is going to
look off it's off to me I need Revenge I
I'm a very Petty
person I want blood but that's also a
virtue right like it's for for really
religious people it is a virtue for to
be like yeah cuz you're not holding hate
you're just relaxed and then the mindset
of like if I hold this in my heart
forever they win you know that type of
[__] like a lot of people think way I
think they're wrong I think you should
always get revenge that's not a win yeah
it's a [__] it's a win when you dunk
on them yeah exactly right as a
Christian I think I think it's a win
when you're like when you're serious
Christian to be able to forgive
something of that magnitude is like a
Proving Ground of like I am this person
with this faith that means there's like
not a lot of Christians in America then
yeah it's hard man when I'm at the
Pearly Gates the first thing I'm going
to ask is like hey were you keeping
[__] score how did I do did you see
my game out there did you see my [__]
game hey pull up my Stats come
see I got them all back baby I got some
threes I got I was sinking threes in
pull from
[Music]
half